wait it's this movies in favor of free
speech oh I didn't know that I thought
it was against free speech and I want
nothing to do with this piece of garbage
this Friday the film can we take a joke
premiered at dock NYC America's largest
documentary film festival it chronicles
the rise of outraged culture and its
effect on stand-up comedy and free
speech reason TV was on the scene at a
pre-party at the comedy sellers village
underground where filmmakers comedians
and free speech advocates were eager to
sound off about threats to free speech
and thought following a week of
high-profile anti speech protests on
college campuses like Yale and Mizzou I
was doing a comedy podcast at the Comedy
Cellar back in 2012 and there was this
guy Li camp on the panel and he was a
self-described most liberal person on
the panel and he said you know I really
don't like playing campuses anymore
because I can't use my best stuff seeing
a comedian not wanting to play campus I
was like wow that that's interesting
comedy is a great leveling power because
dictators and evildoers and so forth
they don't like to you know shocker
we made [ __ ] up and you see this even on
much much smaller level like on college
campuses where the administrators
surprise surprise don't like to be made
fun of you tonight other she's actually
pretty cool I actually we had some
friends in from town and we went to the
American Girl doll store right there
which by the way apparently you have to
spend half your salary on one [ __ ]
doll which turns out is from China and I
was thinking I could buy a kid from
China for less than it cost me and see
if I told it that at college I'd have to
say I am completely anti anti human
trade I do not well its first comedy and
colleges are concerned I have a new
mantra it's more punchlines less pouting
because people need to put their good
big-girl panties on and realize your
joke is a joke but humor
is an elaborate awesome thing that
actually can have valid points to it it
can make you think it can stretch you
and it can take you to being a better
person which is not why people go to
college about fifteen years ago I was at
the Comedy Cellar with my my brother
Matt who's a stand-up comedian and
someone there was offended by one of the
jokes and comedian said and we looked at
each other like this is so weird
did you come to a comedy club to get
offended maybe the events of this week
in recent times maybe it signals that
we're reaching peak crazy and that
people are going to finally say wow you
know this is this is a little too nutty
but on the other hand the outraged mob
could just keep plowing ahead people in
power who want to shut up people who
want to criticize them and so you know
make telling a joke about something is
the first way to you know make sure that
you're still free as long as we can tell
jokes we're still free I love doing this
I love spreading joy and I love that you
guys are all here supporting such a good
cause because humor and comedy and
laughing at even gruesome [ __ ] is
awesome it's what makes the world go
round
right